when you hear Tech you might think
Google glass coffee devices more Google
Glass but fancy dress it was a carnival
atmosphere for the London leg startup
bus Europe an event that Rams 200
budding Tech tycoons on eight coaches
covering 10 000 miles in less than 72
hours with the sole goal of imagining
building and launching the next big
thing
startups by Design is meant to be
painful and it's actually accidentally I
think near to this thing that we call
constraints-based Innovation where if
you put constraints on people and
impossible constraints it actually
forces them to think in a much more
productive way it's really 40 hours that
they're awake straight and that's a work
week you know some are so desperate to
get on the bus names are pulled out of a
hat to land one spare seat
The Chosen Few have the chance to
impress investors on arrival at one of
Europe's key Tech events
sort of have a network in London and a
network in the
I don't have a network
a country so for me it's about meeting
people but ultimately the prize is much
greater one lucky group will land a trip
to Tech Mecca a chance to work at Google
and Facebook in Silicon Valley
so is the US so far ahead Europe's best
brains really want to leave
if you want to go worldwide you've got
to sell to Brazil China it's not just
you actually got sell everywhere where
your base I don't think what to do with
it now you're talking about investor
networks lots of the investing networks
in the US are much bigger than over here
so no matter where the buses visit
there's only one location in mind for
these ambitious entrepreneurs according
to the startup buses founder it doesn't
really matter where they go it's really
a globalized economy and labor is moving
around and it's not a bad thing that
people spend a few years overseas
because you want that movement because
that is what's going to build the London
Texan